Hello everybody, it is the second of May 2018.
We have a lot of questions on tonight's Zoom call
to go over.
So let's get started at the end.
I'll open it up for questions.
If you just joined us, you are muted.
And now I know that if we start getting feedback,
somebody jumped on and I have to mute everybody again.
So I'm learning this whole technology as we go.
So some questions we have.
Here's one question.
Do you have something for sleep?
If a hard time's going to sleep and stay to sleep.
This is a loaded question because there's so many
possible causes of inability to fall asleep
and stay asleep.
Really, if a hard time falling asleep
is a totally different problem than someone who wakes up
and then can't go to sleep.
So if you are somebody who is waking up
and then you're and can't fall asleep,
that is, let's just walk through some possibilities here
because there's a lot of different possibilities
when we talk about sleep issues.
So number one is I can't fall asleep.
I go to bed, that's what's called insomnia.
But it's time to go to bed.
It's really my time to go to bed.
I got to get up at six o'clock and it's 10.30.
I'm going to bed and you lay at bed for an hour or so
before you could fall asleep.
That's insomnia.
So insomnia can be caused from multiple things there.
We've spoken about it in past Zoom calls.
Stop looking at screen time several hours before bed
because watching a screen like a computer screen
or your phone screen or a television screen,
the screens are functioning at a very high hertz.
60, 50 to 60 hertz is what they're functioning at.
That is a training your brain at 50 to 60 hertz.
Your brain waves are only supposed to be functioning
at the highest hertz of about 28 hertz,
which is a high beta wave.
So you're training your brain at a super high beta wave.
Of course, your brain can go that high,
but you're in training your brain to be a high beta wave.
Nobody can fall asleep in a high beta wave.
You have to get down to a theta wave to get to sleep somewhere
between five and 15 hertz to be able to start to fall asleep.
So it's difficult to be looking at your phone
and it's time to go to bed.
So you put your phone by your side of your bed
and you try to go to sleep.
That itself doesn't allow your brain
to get to a theta wave to get to sleep.
That itself could be a problem.
So number one, you can't fall asleep.
Stop using screens several hours before you go to bed.
Well, I do that already and I still can't fall asleep.
Okay?
Yeah, the thing that could be taking places
is there a little teeny gland in your brain
called your PDL gland that's supposed
to be secreting melatonin at the time
before you're supposed to go to sleep.
So you can use some melatonin.
It's typically recommended that you use
about three milligrams of melatonin,
about a half hour before bed to help fall asleep.
We have melatonin in our store.
We also have a product called insomnetol in our store
that has some melatonin, has some valerian root
and some other herbs that can be very calming
to help you fall asleep.
So number one, screen time, number two,
low melatonin levels, melatonin levels
are also controlled and go along
with an inverse relationship with cortisol.
Cortisol is a stress hormone.
So if I'm under a lot of stress,
this is why if you have ever been under a lot of stress,
it's difficult for you to fall asleep.
So it is because if you have a lot of stress,
you have a lot of cortisol secreted in it.
You have a lot of cortisol flying through your bloodstream.
You won't make melatonin or you won't release melatonin
from the PDL gland and it's going to be difficult
to fall asleep.
So dealing with stress levels,
that's why sometimes people do better exercise eat at night
before bed because it can help bird off
some of that cortisol and that helps them,
their body release melatonin to help them fall asleep.
So exercising before bed can be beneficial in that case.
There's other reasons why you can't fall asleep
and I could, we could talk for a long time
on just the sleep patterns.
Now, waking up in the middle of the night
and not being able to fall back asleep has to do
with other issues that could be very complex too
but usually are not related to melatonin.
They can be related to adrenal burdo
because at night, so at night you're in a fasting state.
So you have it eaten since night of clock
or something like that and now you're fasting
but there's one part of your body
that needs glucose all night long.
Your muscles don't need a lot of glucose
because you're not exercising.
The rest of your body doesn't need a lot of glucose
so you're not doing a whole lot of activity.
Things are in a stall mode while you're sleeping
but your brain is always active.
In order for your brain to continue to be active,
it needs glucose.
Your adrenal release cortisol at night
to stimulate glucose breakdown of glycogen stores
in the liver to keep a steady glucose level
to keep your brain alive.
So what a person says, I wake up about water to,
I fall asleep just fine.
I wake up about water to a clock
and I can't fall back asleep again.
That's usually because their adretals are deficient.
Probably because of past stress, maybe current stress
but their adretals are deficient.
So they need some adaptogens or some adrenal support
and if you can support the adrenal to get
healthy adretals again, then all that whole system
can start working again.
There could be some other things with some mineral deficiency
that can cause a person to not be able to fall asleep
or not be able to get back asleep at night either.
And as this little diagram talks about leg cramps,
that would be the mineral deficiency issues.
Acid reflux, well that's good back to gut health.
And other issues like pain,
so pain can be an issue that keeps a person up
and doesn't allow them to get back asleep.
I would suggest if you really have issues
with insomnia and sleep patterns
that you do call and make an appointment
to talk about them if you can't deal with it,
to get figured out with some of the brief things
I spoke about here.
Another thing to try is the insomnia programs
on your right.
We've had people say they've tried them,
but it didn't help at all.
We've had other people say they tried them
and it was a miracle thing for them.
So melatonin, think about that.
Side note on that, high dose melatonin has been showed
in several studies that it's been helpful
for some cancer patients to help with their cancer.
So melatonin is not contraindicated for cancer patients
that can be helpful for cancer patients.
So I would not discourage you from trying melatonin,
take, you know, I don't want to do that,
that I'm going to be depended upon it.
It can be good for your kids or so.
I would say definitely try melatonin.
Insomnia solved chronic we have.
We've had a lot of people with very good success with that.
There's a whole bunch of other reasons
why a person isn't fully asleep.
Well, part of it has to do with glutamate levels.
Hopefully with most of our cancer patients,
we have been working on reducing glutamate levels
because high glutamates will keep you awake.
That's the neurotransmitter.
That's an excitatory neurotransmitter for your brain.
So hopefully you're already working on glutamate levels.
So that's not the piece that's keeping you awake
because remember glutamate converts to glutamate
and feeds cancer, so we don't put high levels there
for other reasons.
But if you have more trouble than the deads are here,
maybe we could get into it at a whole call itself.
But I know I address some of these in other Zoom calls.
Next question.
I've been reading a lot about curcuit
and what it does for cancer should I be taking curcuit.
So number one, remember we put your protocol together
because that's what it tested for you.
I'm not opposed to people adding supplements
to the protocol that I created.
Better fact, I'm not God
and you have to do what God is leading you to do.
So I have some patients that I strongly recommend
that they don't be taking X, Y and Z supplements
and yet they still take them because they feel led to do so.
Well, I'm all in support of what you have to do.
So I'm not, I don't know everything
and you have to do what God's leading you to do.
That being said, curcumin is one of those
that everybody could take.
So curcumin is the active form
of the nutraceutical that's found in turmeric.
Turmeric is an Indian spice.
You can take turmeric directly as a spice
but it doesn't absorb very well.
You take it with black pepper
and a fat helps that.
The fat actually helps the absorption.
The black pepper helps the half life in your body.
We use a curcumin that is in a form
that is readily absorbed.
It has a lower half life.
It's a C3 reduct a tetrahedra curcumin or curcuminoid.
But that's the product that we have.
So I have multiple videos just on curcumin
and you can find those on the resources page of our website.
So I am a huge fan of curcumin.
Curcumin is very good for a lot of different things.
Curcumin is good to help decrease
to a metastasis, decrease tumor, cell growth,
it's known to stimulate apoptosis.
And most people use curcumin for just inflammation
to decrease inflammation, very, very helpful.
So I am very pro-curcumin.
We have our own C3 curcumin.
It's called curcuclear.
And each capsule is equivalent to about one gram curcumin.
So typically, when you're dealing with cancer,
one to three grams is spied.
Some cancers like multiple myeloma have been shown to need more
and do real well with more.
We have multiple myeloma patients.
Seven of them have tested out fantastic on it
and we have them up to eight grams of curcumin.
So that's a lot, but it's been shown to be very helpful.
Can you take too much curcumin?
You could take too much anything.
So yes, so if you have a tested for it,
meaning with me, I'd say one to three grams
should be your maximum dose.
Next question, one of the best things to do
after removing a cancer is two or so.
What's the best thing to do after surgery,
really is the question.
If I have surgery and I have a cancer diagnosis,
what should I do?
Well, I made a video, maybe it isn't published yet,
it's a blog post.
I don't think I scheduled to publish it.
It's not going to be published for a week.
So lots of times I'll write blog posts that I'll put them out
in time so that my blogs come out in a series.
But it's on dealing with surgery.
There's a new study that just came out
that actually confirms something that I've said a hundred times
that we don't want to have elective surgeries
if we could help it when we have a cancer diagnosis.
That's why I've been told, I've told you guys multiple times
that I'm not a big fan.
Okay, I had bestectomy because I had breast cancer.
But now I'm going to have surgery to have breast implants.
And I understand I'm not a woman,
and I don't know what it's like to not have breasts
and all the emotions that go along with that.
But when we perform a surgery of any kind,
even to remove a cancer's tumor,
the way your body has to heal itself
is to up-regulate IGF-1.
Remember, IGF-1 is your growth hormone initiator.
So IGF-1 levels are how you heal.
So in order, if I even cut myself,
how do I heal that cut?
IGF-1 levels are up-regulated,
meaning increased, and that stimulates an increase
in that m-tore pathway.
Ever we've spoken about that, and nausea.
So when we up-regulate the m-tore pathway,
it increases my ability to heal
by that wood is scarred over,
and I heal nicely and go,
wow, look at how healed so well.
That's wonderful.
But you did so by up-regulated m-tore and IGF-1 pathways.
When you up-regulate m-tore and IGF-1 pathways,
with a cancer diagnosis,
it is, I hate to say it,
but it is like throwing gasoline out of fire.
So we want to do things to down-regulate the m-tore
and IGF-1 after surgery.
So the best way to down-regulate m-tore
and IGF-1 is through fasting.
But I'll say it again,
cancer patients cannot fast more than 24 hours at a time
if we're talking about a true water fast.
Do that's why we talked about doing intermittent fasting
or what's called time-restricted eating.
So you actually are fasting every day,
but it's only a fast of maybe 16 to 20 hours a day.
If your time-restricted eating is limited to four
to eight hour window.
So if you're eating within a four hour window,
which would be a pretty tight time-restricted eating window,
that means you're fasting 20 hours a day,
which would be a great thing for cancer
because you'll have down-regulated IGF-1,
down-regulated m-tore, down-regulated PDKs.
You could get the same benefit by using the fasting mimicky diet.
So you go to the fasting mimicky diet five days a month
and you stick to the diet that we put you on,
you're gonna have down-regulated IGF-1
down-regulated m-tore, down-regulated PDK.
You do not wanna go on a water fast
for more than 24 hours if you have cancer
because you'll have, it'll up-regulate IGF-1.
The only exception to that is,
if you're doing chemo and you're going on a water fast,
day-previous to the chemo and then the day of chemo.
It's a lot of information if you have questions,
you could post another question on Facebook,
rewind this video and listen to that again.
The best way to heal from a surgery,
if you have cancer, is to try to down-regulate.
Keep a head to let IGF-1 in m-tore and you do that
through the fasting mimicky diet.
That answers that, that will help.
So if you have more questions on that, feel free to call
or to ask on Facebook.
Next question in my situation,
of course, would you recommend doing another IGF-IG?
IGF-G test in three months.
So the answer is so everybody's different, right?
So if a person was diagnosed with cancer before they came to us,
which was obviously everybody,
and we do an IVG test and let's say they were stage two cancer.
And we do an IVG test and they're below 20.
So they're at, let's say, a 16.
And they're feeling great.
We don't know what they were before.
But if they were stage two, stage three, stage four,
they were for sure above 20 at some point in time.
So now they're below 20.
And that's great.
By what word of caution that maybe I don't make this
well spoken enough,
is that do not get complacent with your protocols.
I have seen doing this for 20 years
and I've been doing this with cancer patients.
I've had cancer patients stage four
that were given three weeks to live.
Two years later, they're feeling great.
When one guy he had a back brace on,
he couldn't barely walk.
He was at a full body, one of those plastic strap braces,
all over his back because he had kids are all through his spine,
all through his body.
They gave him weeks to live.
He, this was two and a half years after that,
he had no body brace or anything anymore.
He hadn't seen him for about six months.
He comes in my office literally and falls onto,
and I'm not exaggerating, falls onto the front desk,
nearly falling down with this great,
and I'm like, oh my gosh, what's going on?
I ran out to the front, this is my other office.
What's the matter?
And he was like collapsing his wife,
who had driven him there, had parked the car,
came in and said, he's doing really bad, he's doing bad.
He stopped using the right three months ago.
It stopped taking his stuff four months ago
because he was convinced that Dr. Cutters
cured him with this cancer.
Well, first of all, I've never, ever, ever told anybody
that they're cured of cancer
because I don't even believe that.
I had number two, I didn't do anything.
So I don't cure anybody, and that's just the facts.
Do not stop what you're doing, I don't care.
How good you feel, I don't care.
How good your IVG test comes back.
So rule number one, do not stop what you're doing.
Rule number two is when should I do it over the IVG test?
Well, really the only honest answer is
it depends on how deep your pockets are.
So it's $450 to the test.
If money is not really an issue and you've been blessed,
you may want to do a test every month,
but still even at that, it might be overkill.
If you're doing really well,
if your score was a 16,
do you really need to do it every month?
No, but if you want to make sure
that you're going to catch it,
if it's going the wrong way, it might be good.
So when I say three months, I'm just guessing two.
So there is no protocol here.
So this is a very new test.
We're creating protocols and we go here.
So is the three months a good window?
It seems reasonable to me.
How are you doing?
How are you feeling?
If there's a turn for the worst in that category,
be like, what's wrong with me?
I'm just feeling like I'm dragging it
and I don't know what's wrong with me.
Well, if you can't get in here to get tested again,
then maybe we should run another IVG test.
So everybody's a little bit different.
You're going to have to make the call.
I'll give you a range.
One to three months would be a good range
for everybody, I don't care what your score is.
But certainly, if your symptoms take a turn
for the worst, you should do it before that.
Next question.
My ecologist recommended drinking tea
from Graviola leaves to fight cancer.
First of all, I want to know your ecologist name
because I have never heard an ecologist
recommend anything natural.
That is fantastic.
Do you have knowledge or an opinion of this?
The good question, I think Graviola is great.
Graviola is, or souresop, is in our medicinal mushroom
number, what our miracle mix number one.
So we test people of this.
So if you're, I'm not taking that.
Well, then you probably don't need Graviola.
So again, this gets back to the, should I take curcumid?
Except I'm much more in favor of you taking curcumid,
even though it didn't test at you versus taking Graviola.
So understand, I put this little thing in here
because it says anti-cancer fruit.
10,000 times more strong than chemotherapy
and killing cancer cells.
I put this in here because I was looking
for a picture of Graviola.
I found this, and this is a warning.
Okay, when you start seeing these on your Facebook feeds
and stuff, oh, this, this, this fruit
or this herb kills cancer 98% of cases.
Okay, that's a giant red flag for me
because those are just lies.
Because if you could put cancer in a petri dish
and then you put Graviola in there,
it would probably kill it.
But if you put cancer in a petri dish
and you just left it for a few days,
it would probably die too.
So you gotta be careful of these kind of things.
That's all I'm saying.
Don't fall prey to things like this.
Like, oh my gosh, I better be taking Graviola
because it's the best thing in the world.
It is a great thing.
If you are taking armenisinal mushrooms,
you already are taking Graviola.
So just so you know that.
If you did not test for mushrooms
and I don't have you on that,
and you're not taking it outside of what I gave you,
then you're not taking it.
I don't have trouble you taking it.
If you feel like to do that, no, you don't.
Actually, I got the name of the doctor,
oh, it's from Cancer Treatment Centers of America.
So that makes a little bit more sense.
They're much more following their own protocol.
And he says that the chatted me
wherever gave me this question
that that doctor is also in favor
of medical marijuana.
Great, fantastic.
So you got some, this is one of the beautiful things
that I never tell anybody
that oncologists are need awful people
that just want to give you drugs.
It's just oncologists are typically
locked into a system
where they don't really have any other choice.
So remember, when I got my degree
by fellowship at an integrative of kids or therapy,
everybody else was in the medical profession there.
And I asked them, oh, this is great
that you can use this in your practice.
The startling comment that I got
and I was a little naive at the time
was that they said, no, we can't.
We can't use any of this at our practice.
We're just learning this for our family
because they literally have their hands tied
in what they can recommend
or they will lose their job.
So they just, they don't,
it's not that they're all just bad people
to try to push chemotherapy drugs on you
that you might not want.
Oh, there is some that fall into that category, I'm sure.
It's just they don't have any other choice.
And so partly in order to justify their position
and what they do, they just don't learn this stuff.
I can't use it anyhow.
So yes, Gabiola is a great thing to help with cancer,
but there's a hundred other great things
that we test for to help find cancer.
But every one of those they, everything that we use,
there's probably some little graphic
that's floating around the internet
that says something exactly like this
that it kills kids or 95% of the people.
They're just lies.
So just don't buy into these kind of things either.
So have a balance there in everything you do.
Another question, can you share your daughter's recipe
for homemade sunscreen?
Well, I didn't have time to contact her
for homemade sunscreen.
All I did is Google it.
So here is a recipe for homemade sunscreen.
This slide it talks about the SPF features
of all the oil, coconut oil, zig oxide.
You do not want to use the data,
nano, nano-nized zig oxide because it's absorbed.
And that's what could be dangerous.
That's what's in the store bought,
not the natural ones, but the store bought sunscreens.
Red raspberry seed oil, carrot seed oil,
shea butter, and how much you use of this,
these things that it's going to give you
more of an SPF protection.
But here are some sunscreen ingredients.
I'll leave this up on the screen while we talk
about any other questions that are going to open it up.
So you could look at this and save this for later.
And you could certainly Google it as well.
All right, so now I open it up.
Everybody is unmuted.
Does anybody have any questions about what we,
or anything else?
Dr. Connors.
I have a question about the lymphatic system
and all the detoxing.
I mean, I guess with everything that we're doing,
like I'm doing the infrared sauna and then the rife
and then the food and the juicing and enemas.
So a lot of detoxing.
So I get bouts of fatigue.
Overall, I feel good and then I'll get bouts of fatigue.
And then when I was at my functional doctor
on the bio resonance machine,
it showed my lymphatic was sluggish.
I jump on the trampoline.
So my question is, can the detox, of course, make us fatigued
and can it slug up the lymphatic system?
Good question.
All right.
So what is detoxification?
So detoxification is getting bad things out of your body
that we don't want to their body, right?
So where are these bad things
that we're trying to get out of the body?
So everyday detox is what's taking place.
So let's take a step back.
In a perfect world, you're exposed to different toxins.
So even 300 years ago, you're exposed to toxins.
Maybe not the same ones that we were exposed to now.
There was no mud, said to.
There was no fertilizer.
There were no chemical spread on fields.
But there was coal burned for heat all the time.
So there was a lot of byproducts of coal in the air.
You look at old pictures of cities and they're black
in the city, the bricks of the building
were black and such because coal was burned everywhere.
There were other toxins that they were exposed to.
Not maybe so many harmful chemicals,
but there was exposure to a lot of different toxins.
That being said, it is imperative
it is imperative that your body is detoxifying.
So if you breathe that cold acid, it went into your bloodstream
and into your bloodstream, then it went through the liver
and it went through that phase one, phase two, phase two,
point five, dumped into the bile, dumped into the small attested,
dumped into the toilet.
And as long as my, those pathways were ample enough
to deal with the amount of toxic exposure,
I never became toxic because you aren't what you eat,
you aren't what you absorb, you are what you don't get rid of.
So as long as I was on a daily or weekly basis,
getting rid of all the things that I was exposed to,
then those things never stated by system
and I never became quote unquote toxic.
That is why there were less amounts of cancer
back 300 years ago.
And if you took out the factor of birth, death set birth,
a death, death set early age or deaths below the age of sex,
people were living just as long 300 years ago as they are now.
So don't buy this, you're never getting more cancer
because people are living longer, because that's not true.
So if you're getting rid of everything
that you're exposed to on a weekly basis,
then you're not getting them, you're not toxic.
What do you mean?
How would I be toxic?
Well, if I'm not getting rid of everything
that I'm exposed to on a weekly basis,
these toxins circulate through the blood
and I will either die or my body will shunt these toxins
to my cells and that's what happens.
So toxins are not getting through the pathways
because we're exposed to an overabundance of them
or the pathways aren't working correctly.
So the toxins are shunted to a cell
and then those cells store toxins, heavy metals,
poisons, chemicals, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
So all these chemicals that we're exposed to
are settled in the cells.
That's how cancer starts.
So, die-de-die person of the time, they don't cause cancer
and I could live to 120 years old and die
and then have somebody cut open a slice of my body,
smear a cell slice onto a slide
and look at it under a microscope,
an electron microscope would say,
wow, look at all these hydrocarbons,
look at that benzene that's in that cell,
look at the mercury, look at the lead.
Oh my gosh, this guy was full of toxins
but as long as it didn't interrupt
any of the metabolic pathways, it didn't cause disease.
Problem is it interrupts the metabolic pathways a lot
and if it interrupts the metabolic pathway
in the nucleus of the cell that is
essential for cell replication, that's what's called cancer.
So if mercury in my cell interrupts
my cell replication cycle, it's caused cancer.
So we need to detox, well, how do we detox?
Well, we have to improve phase one, phase two,
phase two point five, phase three detoxification pathways
and we do things like everything that I have you
guys doing that will also help my cell,
my cells push stuff back into the blood
so it could detox.
Now, my cells aren't always gonna push things back
into the blood, they're gonna push things
outside of the cell membrane.
So, membrane cells are this little round thing
that has membrane around it
and when we're getting rid of the toxins in that cell,
it pushes it outside of that cell,
outside through the cell membrane
into this space called the extracellular space.
That's the space between the cells.
The extracellular space is a fluid matrix
with proteins and a bunch of junk
that the cells just gave off
because they're trying to clean themselves out
and then that extracellular space is drained
by a open ended capillary system called your lymph system
which you can think of as a storm sewer.
So, your cells are like houses
that are throwing the garbage out into the street
and now the garbage has to be cleaned up and take it away.
Otherwise, we just have a whole bunch of garbage
sitting at our street, aka the extracellular spaces
and that doesn't make us feel good.
So, we could get a sick feeling, tired, sluggish,
not feeling well because we are detoxing very well.
The cells, but we're dump it into the extracellular space
and if we have an overabundance
that our lymphatics are draining well,
then we could have sluggish feeling dead.
And we could also have sluggish feeling
if our lymphatics are working
but it's getting back to the liver and phase one,
phase two, phase two point five is it working well
and we've talked about that a lot.
That's why we use things like milk,
and nerve two accelerator and keep what accelerator
and pond what assist at detox accelerator
and phosphatinal collided, subbitters and binders.
So, that's why we're doing all that stuff.
So, you gotta look down the line.
Is it a problem with the liver cell itself?
Is it a problem with the liver getting it into the bile?
Let's look a little farther back.
Is it a problem with the lymphatic system
being able to pick it up?
Is it a problem with the toxins that get into the lymphatic system
but it's not getting back to the blood?
Well, how does the lymphatic system work?
Well, the lymphatic system works
by contraction of the muscles.
So, if all were doing a sitting around on the couch,
eating healthy bond buds,
we're still not gonna detox very well
because we're not getting lymphatic drainage
and lymphatic movement.
But you said, I'm doing the soda.
I'm doing the Chiba sheet.
I'm doing Skid brush sheet.
I'm doing exercise and I'm contracting muscles
but I'm feeling sluggish.
You could be doing everything right
in the symptoms that you might be getting there
because you're really doing a good job
of cellular detoxification.
And it's, you're kind of overwhelmed with the liver
but you're doing everything right
and this too shall pass
and you're cutting out and go through that a little bit too.
So, you might think about a couple things.
Well, I've been doing this for a couple of months
and I'm still getting sluggish.
You could slow down on some of those things
and just take it easy
and maybe you're going too fast
and overwhelming your liver.
It's not that we need to support the liver anymore.
We're just going too fast and overwhelming
and see if that makes a difference.
But you gotta look back at all the pathways that go
whereby maybe over-deleted,
whereby where do I need some support?
Maybe I don't need any support.
I just need to drink some water and cool off
for a little bit.
Try some of those things.
Okay, thank you.
That's very good.
Dr. Connors?
Uh-huh.
Mrs. Cork, can you hear me okay?
I can.
Okay.
How many minutes a day or every day
or whatever should I use that little trampoline?
Six and a half.
Oh, I can't, sorry.
It's in a half minutes.
I'm okay.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
Yes, I'm sorry.
There really isn't a time period.
So usually the trampoline, the trampoline
is a great Levanic detox tool.
But it's something you gotta work up to too
because if that's if it's something you're due to,
six and a half minutes can be overwhelming.
You gotta go slow and get up to it.
So it's exercise.
So there really is it.
Yeah, there is.
You kid over exercise, right?
That's that good.
Right.
You could get up to a half hour today.
That'd be fantastic.
So that's what I'd choose.
Okay.
I think that'd be a good thing to shoot the work.
And then I have another question.
Is that okay?
Uh-huh.
It seems as though my right arm is getting bigger.
Is that because I'm not draining or?
Most likely, yes.
Either that or you gotta stop pump it out
or with your right arm would start doing both arms.
Yeah, right.
It's probably some lymphatic blockage.
And next time you come in because you're local here,
we should check that.
Okay.
So we want to do the LBG and open that up.
We want to check and see if there's any growth there
in your lymphatics.
What's LBG?
What's that?
That's a therapy we have the lipid generator.
Oh, that one.
Okay.
Yeah.
So do I need to make an appointment to see you then
or just do that?
Yeah, do that.
That's the next time you come in just tell Jevlet you
with a CV.
Okay.
Is next week one day good for you?
I'll be here, but these two thirds did next week.
Okay.
So whichever day.
Okay, sounds good.
Okay, I'll be done.
A question came over.
Okay.
Oh, any other questions from you?
Korky?
I think that's, yeah.
No, I think not right this minute.
I can't think I had probably 10 or 12 when I called,
but you know, it goes.
Oh, somebody else asked.
A question came over the chat.
Do you know anything why not to drink grapefruit juice
with taking medication?
Yes, it's because it blocks a specific pathway.
I can't remember the metabolic pathway,
but that's the reason it actually accelerates that pathway
and you actually lose the medication for what I remember.
So it's, that's the grapefruit juice with medication,
but I can't remember which pathway it is.
Any other questions?
Dr. Connors, it's Lisa again.
Yeah, you already asked a question.
I know.
Is there any, any closer to Florida?
No, we don't know what we're going to be able to do with that yet.
It's just, it's hot down there.
So no, I don't know what we're going to be.
And we're still really worried about it
and what we're going to be able to do.
So, all right, anything else?
Is Michelle working on that presentation for that?
Oh, yeah, that was the other question if you were shared.
Michelle is actually, she's doing her,
what her thesis, that.
So she's putting a bunch of stuff together and,
so we're actually going to turn it into a book.
So that'll be good.
But did you have any specific questions of it?
Well, I mean, I just don't know my limits like for CBD oil.
It's supposed to be helping with inflammation and pain.
And I'm only taking 10 milligrams a day right now.
And it's not helping with pain at all.
So 10 milligrams of CBD oil is really low.
Okay.
So that's where getting the higher dose CBD could be beneficial.
And it could be, if you take us a super,
and then you don't necessarily have to take it every day.
You just take it with, with, dealing with breakthrough pain.
So you can stay at a lower dose if you use the higher dose just to knock it down.
But yeah, you're going to have to go.
Some days, maybe 10 times that dose.
Oh, okay, that's the problem.
So I'd bump it up and I'd bump it up slowly to see what was going to work for you.
And I don't want to get kind of pricey.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll end there.
It's been 45 minutes.
Thanks for emailing those questions in Lisa.
Thanks for sharing yours.
Thanks for sharing yours because I forgot to put yours on here.
So thank you, Dr. Connors.
I will see you guys all next week and keep using Facebook.
Thank you.
All right.
Bye.